vois tu ne bouges pas tant dans le
syngaz mais vic n'a pas bougé par le
jean est moi j'ai envie d'y aller vous
êtes bien quand même
pourtant il est rapide quant à julie
elle peut pas s'empêcher de bouger bien
alors combien souligne ami les souvenirs
à part le normand je crois oui c'est la
première fois que j'ai vu de la neige
j'étais tout petit et samassa m'a choqué
et ce qui m'a le plus marqué c'est que
j'ai dit à ma mère regarde moment il
pleut de la purée hélas non c'est vrai
et la maladie c'est lui a conquis va
être très con premier choc
abreu messieurs c'est quand comme mon
père m'a appris que les village people
était homosexuel ouais moi c'est quand
les beatles se sont séparés il est
homosexuel
non mais c'est toujours mieux que nos
jambes le premier mensonge
premier mensonge je n'ai pas j'en ai
beaucoup des mensonges
j'avais choisi jacques je vous dirais un
grand compliment au moins pour les
choses avec philosophie sa a cédé l'an
dernier mensonge premier baiser avec la
langue
bah premier baiser c'est une fixette
yannick miel tourner la langue trop vite
et en plus ça n'ouvre pas la bouche ça
servirait première fois première fois
deux dans un camping avec une belge
première fois à troyes jamais hélas nous
y est les allemands non copine de me
demander à la tolérance
regardez votre caméra et lance un appel
tout de suite c'est à ça que ça sert la
tv je recherche une nounou lors deux
deux nounous non une j'en ai déjà une
wii j'ai déjà ma nounou une deuxième
nous nous tout est accepté
ouais y avez-vous pensé parce qu'à
partir à meaux s'est entassée l'annoncé
là vous êtes vraiment un mec c'est à
dire que quand vous pensez à faire
l'amour à trois vous pensez tout de
suite que la personne supplémentaire
serait une fille est pas un garçon pas
très sympa pour votre fiancée oui mais
non si on faisait l'amour à trois avec
un mec moi j'aurais vraiment
l'impression de faire l'amour avec le
mec qui j'ai pas envie de voir son
machin qui ballotte ça n'attend
maintenant tu seras pseudo tu verras
rien qu'à elle c'est marrant les mails
vous êtes tous les mêmes un première
rupture
le concert sera pêché première rupture
ça s'était très vite c'était une copine
qui est venu france voisine qui est venu
frapper à ma part j'avais 12 ans elle
m'a dit moi y'a béatrice qui voudrait
sortir avec toi je viens t'en faut que
je réfléchisse je suis partie au judo de
trois heures je suis revenue la même
voisine est venue frapper alors moi
j'étais prêt à donner ma réponse samedi
à béatrice qu'elle changeait d'avis à
100 avec christophe et ses produits
rupture je n'étais rien passé mise en
face à l'impasse et à rentrer et était
ceinture bleue comme un des premiers
vrais chagrin d'amour
quand j'ai quitté ma mère pour monter à
paris
que c'est beau ce boulet première
tentative de suicide jamais je n'ai
jamais eu envie de me suicider en plutôt
mourir
non mais après des pétards je ne veux
pas de nom non non non non j'ai déjà
tiré une ou deux taffes mais je suis pas
non c'est pas mon oui bon oui j'en ai
fumé à m
et avait déjà mellick la première chose
que vous faites le matin au réveil bad
matin au réveil j'ai beaucoup de mecs
questionnaire et ça vous n'êtes pas
répondu la même chose est ce que je vais
dire là par contre le matin non non le
matin les matins je devrai bien attendre
appelé le matin je sais qu'il fut un
gros poids de la maintenance le matin et
là il ya des mecs qui vont se
reconnaître moi j'ai la petite érections
matinales
ouais alors alors je laisse pas passer
ça et je fais l'amour même si je suis
tout seul
bien encore allumé des bougies
bon